graduation day for raf recruits
but behind the salutes and the smiles
sky news has heard serious concerns
about raf recruitment policies
it's linked to a drive to boost
diversity
hugely important for any workforce
but there are worries that a push by the
air force to hit diversity targets
is unfairly penalizing white men
sky news has already revealed this
prompted the service's own head of
recruitment to resign
it can now be revealed on the day she
quit
the group captain sent an email
questioning the legality of a specific
order given to her recruitment team
in the email she wrote this direction is
to make offers of employment to
additional women and ethnic minority
candidates solely on the basis of their
protected characteristics and in
preference to non-ethnic minority men
who have successfully passed all
selection criteria ahead of them she
continued this is unlawful as group
captain recruitment and selection i am
not prepared to delegate or abdicate the
responsibility of actioning that order
to my staff
defense sources say the concern was
around whether loading extra women and
ethnic minorities onto certain courses
might amount to positive discrimination
positive discrimination is unlawful it's
where
an employer favors someone by treating
them more differently in a positive way
for example an organization appointing
someone from an underrepresented group
into a role without considering whether
they have the right skills
and other candidates who are better
qualified
but don't share that relevant protected
characteristic are passed over the raf
uses a first-past-the-post system when
recruiting for ranks other than offices
candidates secure a training space on a
first come first served basis once
they've passed each of the steps along
the recruitment process
this includes an interview and aptitude
fitness and medical tests
by contrast course loading appears to
refer to plucking certain candidates out
of the recruitment pipeline or
accelerating them through it to fill
training slots ahead of those who would
otherwise have beaten them over the
finishing line
defense sources say the head of
recruitment resigned because she would
not implement what she believed to be an
illegal order
the allegation raises serious questions
for the head of the raf
air chief marshal sir mike wigston
pictured here on a visit to romania
earlier in the year
a minister came to his defense on friday
saying the service had paused loading
recruitment candidates onto certain
courses while looking at how it can
legally improve diversity levels
absolutely nobody
in the raf or the ministry of defense is
going to allow positive discrimination
for once for any other reason because
it's straight up illegal
if there are avenues for
the chief of the air staff to look at
positive action
then that's fine and he's created
himself room to do that but it must we
must be absolutely clear that no
policy is yet implemented yet defense
sources say the head of recruitment was
challenging an order that was issued in
the last few weeks
an raf spokesperson said we frequently
review our recruitment processes seeking
legal advice to ensure that we're
mindful of our legal obligations any
allegations that we've failed to do so
are investigated without delay
the concern raised in this instance was
addressed by the chain of command at the
time and we continue our work to ensure
recruitment processes remain compliant
with all policy and legal requirements
the head of the air force has yet to
comment publicly
debra haynes sky news